So this transparency is what I want to use to kind of
introduce the term of alpha-blending.
Let's see what that means.
So by doing a multiplication that I have done here with 0.34 before each and
every image, what I've done is basically added kind of
a [INAUDIBLE] do a mixing of different types of things.
So basically what I've done is I've made the original image,
compared to the next one, transparent by 34%.
So in essence transparency is what an alpha is referred to as.
So in essence what actually that means is I've actually converted and given each
one of them and made each of them transparent by 34% from the original image.
This is referred to as an alpha and
it usually varies from 0 to 1 whereas 0 is completely invisible.
Remember if I multiplied by 0 here you would not have
seen Leonardo Da Vinci at all.
If I multiply by 1 you would have seen him completely visible.
Of course it would have had changes to your dynamic range of the pixel values
here, but this guy, Mr. Da Vinci, would have been perfectly visible.
And similarly I could play around with these numbers for all of them.
So alpha varies from 1, 0 to 1, where 0 is invisible and 1 is fully visible.
So, in essence,
one of the ways we could do this is now basically add another layer.
So RGB up to three layers of the image or three channels.
An alpha could be another channel, which would have values from 0 to 1.
And RGB would have, of course, then since the values from 0 to 255.
This additional number, alpha value, could be also be computed and put inside
those channels or kept separately and actually dealt with as a different mask.
And this is an interesting way of being able to now create a separate mask,
which we will then be able to play around with for different applications.
Again, something we will come back to as we look at many examples.